[MUSIC PLAYING]
ED: Hi, I'm Ed from
the Google Maps team
and we're here in London today
as part of our Code the Road
tour.
We're going to be
walking some developers
through building an Android
application with Google Maps.
We're going to be displaying
some data on the map
and building some
functionality to do check-ins
and saving the data
back to Google's cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm not
a software developer
but it was still easy to be
aware of what's happening.
MALE SPEAKER: Very, very
helpful and very, very friendly.
MALE SPEAKER:
Pretty interesting.
I ended up with a working
app, so that's always good.
MATT TOON: Thank you
very much for coming
and thank you very much to the
people who were at the code lab
this morning for staying.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ENOCH LAU: You can say tell
me the time between A and B
next Tuesday at 9:30 AM.
MALE SPEAKER: A
guy from Google who
actually worked on the Google
Map API helped me out a lot.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
I like days where
you have workshops and talks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]